después de las altas temperatura pasó a
la tempestad en todo caso si fue lo que
se vivió este martes aquí en am parís
cuando sobre las seis de la tarde
cayeron unos treinta y siete milímetros
de lluvia eso es prácticamente un mes de
precipitaciones aquí en la capital a
esto se sumaron fuertes ráfagas de
viento de hasta unos 104 kilómetros por
hora según lo registrado por la estación
meteorológica instalada en todo lo alto
de la torre eiffel esto se tradujo por
la calles inundadas en algunos sectores
de la ciudad el agua llegaba hasta por
encima de las rodillas algunos árboles
también cayeron a dos sobre la vía
pública y el tránsito se vio afectado
algunas estaciones de metro en
particular sobre el en el sur de la
ciudad fueron inundadas allí justamente
donde algunos usuarios pues habían
buscado resguardo en medio de toda esta
tormenta el tráfico férreo también
ferroviario también se vio afectado
algunos trenes que tuvieron que ir en
marcha lenta pero ya la situación pues
se estuvo bajo control sobre mediados de
la noche y para esta mañana ya había un
regreso a la normalidad de todo el
transporte público
y en sus alrededores la meteo france que
es la agencia meteorológica francesa
dice que no se batió ninguna récord a
pesar de el episodio violento que se
vivió este martes pero que sí hay que
esperar a nuevas lluvias ahora sobre
todo los ojos están puestos en el sur
del país porque es allí donde se espera
haya violentas tormentas este miércoles
y los siguientes días